so how often do you and I get on
Instagram or Facebook and we see
somebody post something about haters
right and they'll say you'll see posts
that will say don't worry about those
who talk behind your back there behind
you for a reason you know
haters really stands for having anger
towards everyone reaching success
there's a lot of haters out there but to
me I hear a lot of people saying things
about haters but the reality is 90% of
haters are right because if a hater says
there's no way in the world you can do
this business and you don't they're
right if a hater says you're not smart
enough to make it in business and you
don't they're right if a hater says you
know you you can make it you can get out
there and do it you're not smart enough
you're not there right if you don't win
so for me as I was getting a lot of hate
for becoming an entrepreneur starting a
business I listen to every one of my
haters I just don't believe there's a
big difference
I listen to every single haters would
say but I never believed them it's like
you think about Jordan had haters and he
remembered everybody that said something
about them and he said it in his Hall of
Fame speech
Kobe remembered his haters Barack
remembers his haters Reagan remembers
his haters the list is long I'll lead
everybody can go for long - everybody
members their haters but they don't
believe them because at the end of the
day instead of getting upset at your
haters what you want to do is go out
there and win and when you win your
success will be the biggest message your
haters will have to watch for the rest
of their lives without you saying
anything nothing
Oh God
gotta love it